We have just eight days to
go until the 2020 election,
and the election is essentially a baked cake
at this point in time with just days remaining.
The two candidates couldn't be more different. The
number of undecideds is relatively small. We know
the top issues to voters are corona virus,
the economy and the race related protests
that we've seen over the last several months,
followed by health care and a number of other
different issues. And I do think it's important
just to remember that this is a unique election.
The circumstances are particularly different.
We're in the middle of a 100 year pandemic. We've
got the most incompetent president that we've ever
had and that there are really important issues
that neither candidate is talking about
and that are rarely talked about in many
presidential elections. But we need to remember
this large swath of important issues that if
Joe Biden were to win, we are going to need to
get right back to shining a spotlight on. Now,
the point of doing this segment is not to attack
either candidate, per say. It is a reminder about
circumstances. This is not about who we should
vote for. Obviously, for the sake of humanity
and the future of the country, we must vote
for Joe Biden. But all of that being said,
there has been no substantive discussion about as
an example. Labor unions and the democratization
of the workplace. There has been no substantive
discussion about tech monopolies outside of
Donald Trump complaining about how Twitter and
Google treat him unfairly. No discussion of the
massive change to our economy that has happened
and is happening, which means quite simply,
that a ton of those manufacturing jobs are never
coming back because they don't exist. These aren't
trivial things and they go to the core of how
our country has changed and potentially could
change depending on who we elect. And the
reason it's crucial that we talk about this
is that someday the pandemic will be over.
Someday, hopefully, there will be a reasonable
person in the Oval Office again. Hopefully the
latter will happen in January. And we are going
to need to be ready to get back to the serious
work on issues that are sort of higher on Maslow's
hierarchy of needs for lack of a better term.
I'll get back to that idea. But let's go through
the issues. Back in 2016, I talked about
this and it's happening again, which is that
neither candidate will just come out and say a lot
of the manufacturing jobs are never coming back.
Many of the jobs just don't exist anymore
because they've been replaced by technology.
Others aren't going to come back unless we change
our economy so drastically that labor is as cheap
here as it is in Bangladesh and China and other
countries. And of course, our economy is based on
the labor being cheaper there than here. So if we
don't reorganize the economy and keep pretending
that it's just a battle over who can bring those
jobs back, we're in a fantasy world that has to be
dealt with. Neither Trump nor Hillary would say it
in 2016. They would both say, I'll bring the jobs
back. No, I'll bring the jobs back, because it's
not politically advantageous to admit many of the
jobs aren't coming back no matter who we elect. If
you say it, your opponent says that's a defeatist
attitude and it's happening again this election
until we recognize and admit that we won't move on
in terms of figuring out, OK, given that many of
those jobs aren't coming back. How do we organize
structure and supplement our economy? Biden has
done a little bit of it by saying this isn't about
saving jobs in a dying industry like coal. It's
about creating new industries altogether, like
green energy jobs. But both candidates are
very lacking on that issue. Labor unions and
democratizing the workplace. Neither candidate is
saying a word about it other than claiming I have
the support of the unions. Joe Biden has actually
been okay on this issue at times in his career.
Big Amtrak guy, which is a union represented
organization. But looking at the industries
where workers are most vulnerable and figuring
out how do we increase union representation,
how do we change the fundamental dynamics of the
relationships between corporations and workers
to be more like the countries that don't need
as strong of a union presence because they've
dealt with the issues that unions are often
there to to deal with. Talking about employee
representation on company boards, dealing with
stock repurchasing, which just helps shareholders
and executives. If this all sounds weird, it's
because neither candidate talks about it for a
combination of reasons. Trump doesn't talk about
it because he doesn't support any of this stuff.
Biden, again, may support some of it. His
historical views on Amtrak suggests that he does,
but he's not talking about it. Maybe because we
have a five or a five alarm fire when it comes.
Corona coronavirus in the economy. Maybe it's
because he's decided it's not to his advantage.
But either way, we have to get back to that
one. Sanity returns. And then number three,
tech monopolies. Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders did talk about it. Andrew Yang talked
about it with regard to our data, but we're not
hearing about it from Trump nor Biden. Trump
sort of will dance around it when he's mad
at tech companies, which he says are far left
and are being unfair to him. It's
totally self-serving. It's not
actually being dealt with as an issue. And Joe
Biden's not really talking about it either.
In a prominent way. And by the way, the debate
moderators haven't brought up these issues either.
So we can say that there's a lot of blame to
go around here. So the point is not to say
that I have any doubt about who we should vote
for on Tuesday or or now if you're voting now.
It's obviously Joe Biden. And to some degree, we
have an emergency like Corona virus. And so it's
natural that some of these issues would fall back.
If we go to Maslow's hierarchy of needs, if our
basic needs of safety, security and health aren't
met. It's less likely we're going to get into tech
monopolies. And I understand that. But we must
remember that there are major political issues
missing from the campaign right now. We can say
they're missing because of coronavirus. We can say
they're missing because Trump is such a dumpster
fire that until he's removed, we can't deal
with them. And that's fine. But we need a plan for
when we get the ball back. As I've been saying,
Biden winning is getting the ball back. We're not
scoring points. We're just getting the opportunity
to play offense again. We need to be ready to do
it, particularly since there may be a two year
window of Senate and House control, which will
then be be replaced by Republicans taking control
back of either or both the House and Senate.
So very important that we bear this in mind.